hey welcome to winners Wednesday and I'm
going to be introducing you to Becky and
John Becky and John just four months ago
came to the property investors crash
course prior to that they were sat at
home watching other winners on a
Wednesday interviews starting from
absolutely nothing making 60,000 pounds
a year in property profit you're gonna
find out exactly how they did that in
this interview Becky and John
financially free through property tell
me you journey how did it happen so we
went to your crash course in June in
Birmingham and then joined your academy
that was this year yes that wasn't that
long ago no okay and then after doing
the DfE and rent to rent that worked
quite close together for us yes we came
home and you started with deal sourcing
hmm and I started looking for rent to
runs and we ended up with four four
essays okay so that started with I
managed to get one after about 150
viewings I managed to get one between an
estate agent and the landlord yeah
because the rents for that area they
were very high as we were doing that or
not I got a call back off the estate
agent saying that three more landlords
were interested I love how you just slip
out though after 150 viewings like it's
nothing but a hundred and fifty viewings
and one of those viewings John fell down
the stairs well then what can come later
that was not so ago those after we
stopped arrested he's doing a viewing in
a property fell over and what happened
fell down the stairs that I pretty much
got out of there thought I sprained my
ankle got back in the car and that that
view was actually when I we'd finished
our essays so it's like veneks for deal
sourcing but you broke your leg broke my
leg yeah broke just on where I joined my
uncle crazy man is painful you you you
too though I know a lot of people didn't
think you were going to succeeded they
know you were like no one thought you
were I mean I thought you were going to
succeed you do that yeah you pushed a
chair you spoken to the existence I you
know when we've got someone that backs
you it's something successful as you
that's like you can do it guys I believe
in you
that puts in your mind and you go and do
it yeah so and then leaving the crash
course those events are so important for
energy they are the number one most
important thing like we find that when
you go to a crash course is so pumped of
energy you can go out you feel like you
can do anything you feel smash the
property game but you slowly like get
back into society and that energy goes
right it drains out of you then like mum
from the line you've got another crash
course we went to another crash course
after that as well just keep getting the
energy back up yeah then you get back up
that's the best thing about them I want
to talk about the deals and the figures
and the finances and side of things but
first how did you even what should what
are your backgrounds and how did you
come about coming to the crash course
and even figuring out this world I was a
care assistant that I started when I was
14 on minimum wage
and so I started doing my law degree to
try and get a better job and then found
you on YouTube with John don't family on
you yeah John found you on YouTube I
agree to what what happened tells the
story of when John told you about me did
you know he was gonna break up yeah I
was a training course for work and I got
a text off John saying we need to talk
so I thought oh that's my relationship
over the girl that he wants to talk over
we're done the girls at work for like
don't go home then come out with us for
a drink but I decided to go home and I
came home to John laid on the bed going
Becky
you need to watch this guy and there was
you and James Armstrong on the TV on
winners Wednesday winners Wednesday who
would have thought you would be on
Windows Wednesday like six months later
we actually watched that episode and we
looked each other always like we're
gonna be on Windows on Wednesday you
just knew it ya know then that was our
goal then so pretend to crash course
still with that goal I suppose you know
so came out the crash course for the
most smash we're gonna smash this now
yeah so okay so you got the training you
went on all the different courses as
part of the Academy bundle and you went
like crazy like mad people viewing loads
and loads of properties yeah how did you
have the time energy money and resources
to even do that and we I quit my job
before the DfE and rent to run because
they wouldn't give me the time off for
it
oh my goodness so you're like couldn't
be more all out yeah
they suck didn't though yeah they've
pretty much said you either if you
decide to take the time off you can
humping you notice now so I was like
okay do you want it written or just
invert oh oh my goodness so you so you
signed up for the advanced training on
the academy bundle and they were like
you don't have to do that yeah so of
course that I've paid for minimum wage
job are you gonna go for alright so you
quit where did you quit your job I quit
my job after you have to sign out for
the Academy yeah and then we went to the
launch pad run to run event and after
that we look at each other and we just
knew what we needed to do yeah it's
never one but I think partly though
we're so buzzing with energy we would
never rent to rent that if I went back
to my normal job
men's you would've been drained and they
probably would've never gone down the
property path you've got I don't want to
tell people to quit their jobs but if
you're gonna do it you've got to do it
the thing is what you did I I wouldn't
have even been able to advise you to do
because you quit your job I know you
paid for the training on credit cards
yeah and that's not a secret
right no we're quite open about that
right so you had no money you were
working minimum wage job also when you
came to the crash course I mean you had
a lot of both had a lot of anxiety yeah
about that and anxiety so we both have
Asperger's which is an on the autistic
spectrum so that just brings like
massive social anxiety social
awkwardness you I you're quite an
introvert I'm quite an introvert
beca's bit more outgoing and I've always
been taught fake it till you make it you
can cry when you get home yeah
yes so like go into an event of a
thousand people there and they're all
strangers as well as it's an absolute
nightmare but you've got to you've
really got to push yourself back the
conference they like you've got to do it
lots of things you say on stage is
triggering your mind you I it's all
about mindset and pushing yourself at
the comfort so you know it really is
that you can sit at home and be
comfortable basically guarding you and
you don't
gonna go anywhere yeah stay in your job
and a crappy bit of money and your
content what you did was such a massive
risk and I know it's paid off in
dividends but quitting your jobs with
anxiety going into credit card debt and
then being like right now we're going to
propagate if that didn't work it could
have ended terribly much oh yeah yeah
well we thought that though
I think it's something you said in the
past on stage pass this live it takes a
lot managed to be poor and it takes a
lot of energy to be rich what you never
get you into yeah so we always have the
view the well if we don't make it Bernie
back where we started
cetera it's a no-brainer isn't it yeah
it's like it's like best case worst case
yeah I mean what are the likely cases of
those things happening yeah and you knew
that if you do all the training and you
go to town on working hard and you've
got the support around the people around
you you're going to succeed so massive
massive respect and it's just so good to
have you here in my home and being able
to follow you Germany so talk to me
about the deals so you for rent to rent
deals how did you secure them where are
they talk to me about so they're all in
Blackpool two of which are quite close
to like the pleasure beach and the sand
castle very touristy and two of them are
quite close to two hospitals okay and so
they tend to do quite well they tend to
go for a hundred plus pound a night and
then these properties just to really be
clear you've got the keys yeah they're
live yeah
the bookings are coming in yeah you've
booked out the whole of like October and
things ago bookings were really good
yeah I have got a shout out to pass the
property Parminder if you're watching
what a top guy he's really pushed us our
first there say we are until we designed
it to level 10 some pictures and he was
really honest you better took like he's
a rubbish yeah he said you know I've got
some pay and we saw today the Tyrian
designer in and for one plot for one
apartment and then from there on we
learned ourselves yeah you know what
Power Team is it's so important having
the right agents having the right
furnishing companies the designers
channel manager
and just generally support network yeah
I think people think that money in order
to be successful in property money is
the most important thing and then
followed by knowledge and then maybe
network is the opposite I think who you
know and who knows you and then what you
know and suddenly the motive the money
isn't isn't so important I know it's all
about pleasing the client identity
yeah sort of me more about these deals
how did you who did the talk in handed
you secure so I've never actually met
you have they no I mean I was spoke to a
deal was sourcing at the time so back I
was like you do the renter owns and she
actually got them got the keys and
everything and I've helped get them
together we've furnished them paid them
decorating DIY how did you find how did
you find these four houses all these
four no I just when I so Gumtree I was
trying to go direct to vendor because I
thought that we might have issues with
estate agents so we tried where we
actually live with them sometimes
because they do really really well for a
B and B's but we're just getting turned
down and turned down and turned down so
I thought right try different area let's
go to Blackpool Director vendor turned
down and turn down turn down run out of
direct event you just ream landlords
direct off come true yeah
and what were you saying and so I was
kind of explaining what what we did but
kind of made out like we'd already done
it not I said that did but he's very
confident yes this is what we do and
then they were all very interested to
meet me and then when they actually met
me and I explained it in person they
weren't interested so they weren't
interested in the idea of you taking on
their property on a corporate ladder
yeah for anyone that doesn't know what
rent to rent or break the service
accommodation is but what you've been
doing is renting an apartment and then
doing that under a management agreement
and then the property then listing on
booking.com Airbnb different sites like
channel manager company doing it
professionally properly legally with the
right contracts and the right you know
head leases and mortgage and and then
what you do is you pay the landlord a
monthly fee and then anything on top you
keep us profit yeah okay so they weren't
interested so then what happened so then
I thought well I'll try a state agents
even if it's just in practicing what I'm
doing you know if it doesn't work and
about the fifth estate agent in I
explained it to them they knew they knew
what it was so they had this had come to
the viewing I came to the view
then came back to their office and
discussed it with the manager of the
estate agents who then running the
landlord so it's kind of like a
three-way conversation and we got the
first one just before that agent we was
any part of you thinking this is never
gonna work
I don't think so I think I kind of got
beaten down with Blackpool I think we
would get into a point of trying another
other area yeah but it did it did work
and I didn't have doubts it why did you
not have doubts because I've seen other
people do it yes and I've heard other
people that I've met in real life and
are real people that have done it
those people are doing it I've usually
also had nose to deal with so it's not
like it's and I think everyone has
Wednesday they all have same things in
common they've all worked really hard
they've all gone on training and got
they've got the right training got
people around them and they've all been
told know at some point and kept going
yeah but that seems to be the pattern so
and then so whilst we were doing what
our first one and because because we're
these apartments are they're very
expensive for the area and they just
weren't renting out because people in
that area can't afford it wrong or
wouldn't afford it so three landlords
had heard what was going on by the
estate agents and the estate agents got
back in contact with those with three
more properties so receives you got that
one suddenly three can yeah yeah no
what's interesting a good relationship
is always better than a good deal yeah
because it once you've got and that
happens to so many people that layer and
Cheryl
Leslie towel a lot of these people have
come with as ones that no no no no no no
and then suddenly yes and then it's like
yes yes yes floodgates open
I know you've had a really good month of
bookings and stuff and it's occupancy if
you had it was yeah just over seventy
percent
what are you expected over the year
based on the disease to make up those
four properties over the full year on
average it's about eighty percent with
the season being March to November and
every other a B&B pretty much being
booked out 100 percent of the time Wow
okay so what have you predicted
with all the due diligence that you
don't even think that your annual profit
is going to be from the property's
60,000 pounds 60,000 pounds that's a
yeah profit you know I mean that's just
incredible it's great yeah incredible
and even if it's not even if it's 40,000
yeah it's still amazing if something to
build us know what we're making a new
job I was in a thousand pounds a month
if I was lucky
so it's a whole nother world do you ever
pinch yourself and just think this can't
be real
I think I'm not quite there yet like I'd
go out to work and I'd do it but I don't
really think about it I'm very I'm quite
interested I'm very focused on what I'm
doing so I don't I can't not pinching
myself and I I'm more worried about my
next stage yeah
what what what do you think of all those
people or what do they say that all
those people that were saying it won't
work don't do the train in you know it
you're crazy it's a pipe dream you've
got to push yourself out you've got to
get yourself out there yeah it's a pipe
dream if you don't go for your ass and
do nothing about it yeah see if you
don't go to work yeah you've got to try
what you got to lose yeah what you lose
if you can't get a minimum wage job yeah
like get a credit card guys and get an
essay basically - I mean like I never
advised you go and get a credit card and
take out debt because that would have
been that would have been because the
thing is there's good debt in there's
bad - yeah
bad debt is when you get money for
something that's not going to give you a
return good debt is when you borrow
money to do something that's going to
give you a good return and then it's for
like free money but it's only going to
give you a good turn if you implement
and if you do it right so if you go get
a really bad serviced accommodation
property and you get debt then similarly
it's bad debt yeah you need to get
training on it death we've not been
stupid we've like we've got a couple of
credit cards of zero interest for two
years and we was confident in the essays
I would easily pay off in two years yeah
so I'll also you them you've been
selling deals as well yeah so we've got
our own property sorting company called
Kingdom property sourcing yeah we've got
a website called Kingdom property
sourcing calm yeah and we've been
trading now for about six months most of
our time has been spent on the RS
so realistically we've been sorted now
for about 14 days by full-time sourcing
14 done yes you've been focused on it
how many deals have you sold in the last
14 days if n 4 deals you've stopped 4
deals in those 14 days you've not been
charging big fees no we've been letting
them go out for quiet cheap
they've all been 25% above ROI and we're
just getting the money in basically how
much how much have you made in profit
from selling those four deals no for a
half brand four and a half so you ending
just over a thousand pound a deal which
again you making the thousand pound a
month and suddenly you package and pass
on the deal and make a thousand pound
it's it's it's really it's really not
bad it's definitely a better job yeah
work for ourselves yeah we've got an
office at home which is great as well
yeah my walk-in wardrobe has been turned
into an office what has been the thing
that differentiates you like you guys
between other people that don't make it
work what I what's so special about
yangchen definitely it's just getting up
every morning and making yourself do it
and I think we've been quite lucky that
we have each other
because when John's having a bad day I
can kick him out of bed and when I'm
having a bad day he can get me outta bed
and make us make each other go to work
it's mostly me kicking backyard but tell
me about the bad days and lack of
motivation there's no yeah and I think
an element of fear sinks in there but
you've got to stick to a positive
mindset you've got to think yourself out
of that fear as Brancato says push into
it so yeah that's what we do you know we
use been out as a constructive make us
do better how do you how do you do just
mindset you know like you'll have you'll
feel that fear walk away at that point
but we just push into it you've got to
focus ahead your focus board and see the
vision and see the end outcome and I
love what you said John earlier when you
said what's the very worst case because
when you're making a decision if the
worst case is you're going to go
bankrupt and and and it's gonna it's
gonna
ruin you forever that's the worst case
then maybe you shouldn't do that do the
thing or if the worst case is what if I
do that it's gonna be really annoying
I'm gonna lose a few thousand pounds and
I won't have learned a big lesson from
it that's the worst case and then I'm
back to square one but the best case is
of making 60,000 pounds a year in profit
and then I have a lot of time to deal
sourcing and this and then then it kind
of makes sense yeah well we did get it
there but we're very safe that's paying
off our debt and we've got a deal source
and we've fully focus on the awesome us
pretty much a full-time jobs our income
most people think that to be successful
you need to be debt free but I don't
agree I think that I mean if you look at
the richest people in the world most of
them maybe not all of them have debt
yeah it's about the majority of adults
in the country have debt either mortgage
student loan or just credit cards that
everyone has that you've got to choose
what you does for yes if you if your
debts for paying off bills then that's
not great because then it's a downward
spiral if you're running your business
off of using good debt I mean even when
I met with James Caan a couple weeks ago
I said what would you do if you were
starting out all over again from scratch
with nothing and he was like I'd
borrowed money why because he's got the
knowledge to know what to do with the
money therefore if you borrow 10 grand
or 100 grand and you make it you put it
to town and make it work and then the
money that you're making covers the
interest and more then it's just
leverage as long as you manage it very
stupidly if you manage it
yeah yeah what has been the hardest
thing for you John so far like on the
property side of things the most
frustrating the most hardest thing for
me because I've got Asperger's is
getting out there you know like I'm
socially awkward massively socially
awkward and social anxiety so going to
meet a stranger and sometimes I stumbled
on my words and so on but I found
through pushing myself out there that I
don't really stumble so much
yeah and I actually love meeting new
people now I love bringing them up and I
love hearing what they've got to say and
talk about their lives and what they're
doing and their property journey as well
yeah and that's what I really like about
this what were you doing before what was
your job I've had a number of jobs in my
lifetime I'm multi skilled guy but
mainly building yeah manual labor
not because I'm stupid I went to
university and so on but I enjoy it I
enjoy using hands yeah but there's no
money in it you're never gonna get rich
doing it tonight so what what change
then what why are you now able to talk
to people sell deals run a business have
a website like how did that happen
confidence a mindset and just having a
vision yeah you're like straight where's
like I'm gonna be a deal sorcerer yes I
wanna be so sadly company don't you just
take this step by step in away is one of
my mean phrase of life like you know if
you do struggle keep chipping away keep
chipping away because eventually the
little steps will get you there yeah and
the people that you were watching on
Windows whens they're my friends yeah
yeah actually our first crash course we
made friends with a girl there that
actually stayed at our house between the
DfE in the room yeah and she's on the
Academy with us and know what's my last
name I know MA
yeah and Jenna we're quite close with
him so he's come around 2 hours a few
times he's been to a few viewings with
us in Blackpool yeah so yeah actually
about the training and that you've
received and the end the academy in
general and what that's been like I
think it definitely pushed us out our
comfort zones massively post our comfort
zones yeah we have been to other
training courses since then as well and
I've not I've not found them as
energetic and I found around lunchtime I
start being like can we go home if no
one's been to a crash course you pretty
much come from asleep eat at local town
with aloof you know even London can be
sleepy guy you go to the cosmos event
it's very high energy there's a very
high energy and that pumps you with
energy and positive energy and you do
literally leave out there like we can do
this
yeah and and that motivates you to get
on the phone in gym if we hadn't gone to
crush cause ringing up some ringing a
statement on the phone and say uh-oh can
we can we run some proper stuff you just
won't be able to do it yeah you've got
to have some knowledge about it and
you've got to have the high energy yeah
totally I mean straight off the crash
course we were rigging up for viewings
not really knowing what I mean we knew
kind of what we were doing but not
enough to go ahead with it but we
thought well we've stamped the Academy
let's get some practice in yeah
don't you start setting up a company as
well didn't you straightaway to be
honest the dr4 he was very important
yeah the first time ever you mean up
estate agents and talk about something
you don't mean what you're talking about
mmm and straight where you build a
rapport in fact that the DfE rang on
stage in the Lancaster I've got a great
rapport over that day and I still talk
to today yeah and she still has me
properties today and I think it's
important that you make them do it at
the dfx I think if they go home they're
not gonna do it in there you've got four
we do it there in there yeah you've made
them cross the line then it's easier
when they go sometimes people say I just
want to learn I'll do it when I get home
no you were this is this is a it's like
a training program practice ground not
theoretical this is Sam at the
revolution get your patch ring up agents
get its all yeah
there's no time like the present being
friends with people like Ricky and just
the whole being in that world what's it
like compared to say six months ago
before you even knew any of this existed
there are a lot more positive than the
people we were friends with the majority
of them yeah you've got to have a
positive miles that you've got to be
around positive people in fact I've
noted since I started your crash course
of my Facebook's change I'm not reading
to social media so much better
unnecessary evil for the business yeah
and my face was just full of you know
the usual negative local town staff your
old friends and that and now I've got
over 2,000 friends from three hundred to
two thousand friends in four months and
they're all property guys my face was
just full-on positivity you wake in the
morning I'm being a bit down and iced
positive me more come up with something
that makes you jump out of bed I saw
your post the other day that made me get
out of bed yeah it was about you've got
extra 48 hours in the weekend and I was
laid in bed hungover on a Saturday and I
did comment well I can't stay in bed
after
that kinda yeah and I got out of that
yeah it's like it's the weekend now's
the time to get to work yeah yeah you've
got you've got to push yourself out
there like I can't emphasize it enough
yeah if you don't push yourself out
there you're never ever gonna get
anywhere in your life you've got to push
yourself at your comfort zone why do you
think some people don't make it even
even though come on the training and
then will that I just didn't work I
think I think yeah yeah and just
laziness yeah yeah lack of action lack
of action your life you have all these
ideas sit around in your head yeah if
you don't take action they're just ideas
because you know working with me and
being on my training programs my Heights
to see people succeed but ultimately
it's a two-way thing oh I'll go I'll go
I'll make one move and give tools and
ideas and training and and and all that
kind of stuff go through the figures but
then it's down to the student write to
them meet me in the middle and then we
can keep going that way I think that's
very important that you say it's all
about the tools because I think a lot of
people might come to clipped up not
particular or crash course the training
events and take on the knowledge and
think it's easy you maybe get the hands
held and that but yeah you've got to
listen to what you're being told and
what you're being taught and go out
there and take actually because if it
was like a magic wand it's that's
fantastic yeah and and and if I was
gonna come to the viewings with you and
negotiate for you then I might as well
just do it myself while I'm doing is I'm
saying here's what I've done here's how
you can do it but I'm really impressed
with what you do I think it's incredible
what's next in what's the kind of be
ours to buy
okay so when you say bureaus you're
talking about very furbish refinancing
run right to buy a house add value to it
pull the money out rent out and going in
I guess that's more what wealth building
rather than cash flow and I mean it's
both really if you're renting it out
after you'd obviously make sure it had a
good rental income of course but it is
more about the pulling the money out so
you're not gonna slow down maybe
financially for a I'm going to be a
millionaire before 25 why do you want to
be a millionaire what's the strongest
reason why
financial freedom but you've got
financial freedom now yes financial
freedom to do what we want
Oh tell me where tell me the difference
so we're financially free so are
serviced accommodations cover the money
that we were earning beforehand plus any
other bills that we've occurred since
starting property right so do the words
your normal lifestyle is covered by your
property income meaning if you wanted to
you could not work yeah but then
ultimately financially free is what is
is to be able to go out and do what you
want when you want without having to
worry about money right so that's when
your passive income or property income
covers your dream lifestyle and that's
the next goal yes so we want to go
traveling don't we yeah we're top of the
world for a year no that's an cultures I
think we want to move from the Northwest
as well it's a great area for cheap
property but then we want to move
somewhere more in the countryside yeah
where would you be buying the BRR deals
in the northwest that's the best places
to be and you guys know it now about the
back of your hand we're gonna Northwest
very well you've been brought up there
you know the area now you've done all
the property training so from an
investment point of view you can kill it
in there um however you just got all
these properties and you're getting cash
flow coming in financially free you wait
into debt to do it how are you gonna
finance the Bri deals to begin with so
we're gonna hope to do joint ventures
yep and source to raise finance to do it
love that love listen you're gonna
package and sell deals you're gonna do
it venturi people and then just totally
take over the northwest
what would you say to somebody that was
considering going on the crash course or
the you let me do it even even if not
the card if not the Academy at least do
the crash course it's free yeah and I
mean we went we went with the kind of
thing as we'll add to learn something or
we'll have a nice week underway yeah you
know you've not got anything to lose
that yeah so I'm we definitely to learn
something crash course yeah don't think
about it just take action yeah go after
your ass if you want to change your life
to get out there and do it because you
guys you quit your job off
the crash course was it the rent to rent
revolution when you quit your job
what was that program like is excellent
yeah it expected fires straight after
that we've got four si so yeah yeah
that's awesome
well I've really enjoyed chatting you
guys thank you for doing all you doing I
hope to see you back at the crash
courses I might even have to put you on
stage to show you story and cheering you
on all the way thank you very much
Elizabeth cubby if you're watching this
come to the property investors crash
course on me on the house and anyone
else watching this video can also come
I'm gonna leave the link in the
description below if you want to check
out James Armstrong interview he was the
person that got these guys to the crash
course and now they're financially free
you can check out his video right here
if you want to Bach onto the crash
course you can do it in the link in the
description or you can just click right
here and don't forget to subscribe to
the channel so you'll never miss the
interview and you can subscribe over
here I'm gonna keep waiting until you
subscribe
[Music]